wait a minute little hoodie is here
right can we okay
where is he this weekend he's home he's
in LA yeah back at his house
I love your sister's face why are you
laughing like that I don't know how is
that
great he's a really really sweet boy
first on-camera interview about your
love life it's something isn't it crazy
do you want to tell the world art is
that your boyfriend now
not boyfriend exclusive how excited are
you to be here at the Super Bowl I'm
very very crazy is it a little crazy
that you're here I mean I would have
never thought a couple months ago before
all this started that I would be invited
to come to the Super Bowl and be able to
do cool things like this so it's very
crazy okay you have built your tik-tok
audience pretty quick
what does it like to be tick-tock famous
I think it's
surreal because it's weird that people
know my name and it's weird that I get
to do interviews and meet a lot of new
people that it's just amazing it's
there's so many opportunities that I'm
I've been given because of it
speaking of opportunities you've been
given JLo
you're gonna get to see her tonight and
you're here at the Super Bowl hanging
with her tell me about your whole
relationship and how it came about with
JLo so a couple years ago I decided that
my dream is to dance with JLo and she
was on top of my vision board I've
talked about her and almost every
interview I've done whenever they asked
what my biggest dreams are and she's
super talented I got to see her in
concert actually got to see her twice
because the first happens when the power
went out in New York City so we got to
see it twice and my dream was to go to
University of Las Vegas beyond their
dance team because their choreographers
are JLo's choreographers and then like I
had everything planned out and yesterday
I got to meet and dance there for the
first time so it was really a dream come
true
okay how was that getting to dance with
JLo finally and how nervous were you at
first when I first met her and I got to
shake her hand and I was just blank face
I didn't know what to say
and then it kind of set in and tears
just started rolling down my eyes
because this is all I ever really really
wanted to experience
it happened it was really really crazy
okay so you get in there you're ready to
dance you count off and then what goes
through your brain as you're getting
ready to dance with JLo so
I have learned the JLo Super Bowl
challenge before because that's a dance
that they wanted to do so I was ready
and at first you can even see it in the
video that she posted like I got nervous
and I forgot to dance it first but we
repeated it twice the second time I got
it and I was just so so excited and her
dancer is actually there some of that
repairs globals dancers who have also
been falling for a very long time
because they're all crazy talented and
Tiffany Maher was there so it was like
one big dance dream all coming true at
one okay you see this little girl losing
her mind because she just meant your sis
there look look at her she's moving
around car I don't know huh
it's okay come here come here come here
come here come here
okay tell me why are you so excited yeah
we're sick dog
[Music]
so what is it like that all of these
people all of a sudden are coming around
and they're trying to get in there and
they want it and these are people
different places around the country yeah
I think it's like it's the best part of
all of it and it makes it so worth it
because no matter what anyone says I do
what I do for all these people that say
I inspire them or I'm the reason they
got into dance lessons it just makes
everything so worth it and it makes me
so happy that I can say like I'm helping
people in love little way I am like it
just it means the world to me okay we
went and we're gonna tour the hype house
tell me about the hype house and what
makes it so cool what how is it being a
part of that so I don't live there but
there are all my best friends obviously
and it's such a great place to collab
and that's where I got to meet the Lopez
brothers and Thomas and Daisy and Kober
and Alex like all of my now I would say
best friends that I talk to you every
day and it's just such a great place to
dance and create content and we're all
such a genuine friends even without the
cameras being out which is the best part
is it crazy when you look at how many
followers you have and do you know your
exact number right now I actually have
no idea what I'm I know I just hit six
million on Instagram which is crazy I
don't know what I'm out on tik-tok right
now 22 points something
but no those numbers can't even register
in my head that's so crazy
besides JLo Britney Spears is also a
huge fan what's that like and have you
talked to Brittany so I haven't talked
to her personally I actually started
dancing to her music quite a long time
ago because my hip-hop teacher Jake was
a huge fan of Britney and he was like
you're gonna dance to her and you need
to learn this style because it's such a
different style of music to dance to
especially with hip-hop or jazz funk
so I've always been a really big fan of
her music and I love dancing to it for
years now so when I found out she's
posed to me it was like she knows buy it
that's so insane what does it mean what
you hear from stars like that you see
them reposting the stuff that you do it
really it doesn't seem real because I'm
like why why do they know who I'm just
dancing in my room by myself why do they
know who I am it's is it usually you by
yourself or is something nobody's going
it's just you and your room by yourself
doing that's how well that's mostly how
it started and then I got to do more
collabs and dance with my friends and go
to crazy like I just went on a friend's
trip with to Hawaii where we got to make
so much content and just have so much
fun for my friend's birthday like I
never would have thought I was even able
to just do all those types of fun things
because that's what it really is it's
just I'm dancing and having fun first
tell me the story of the Super Bowl and
how it all came together dad because you
did the surprise
well we so someone from the NFL tweeted
actually originally someone from the NFL
did a tick-tock asking Charlie to do
this dance and the woman AJ from the NFL
is on Twitter so I reached out to her
and I said hey we're you know Charlie
would love
to come down and potentially meet JLo
and she responds to maybe we make that
happen and we had some of our friends
take it from there and next thing you
know Charlie met JLo last night what is
it like having a child that is so
digital famous to children really
because I am just watching how they were
acting to Dixie but how was it having to
digitally famous children for the most
part it's like life as usual except when
we're out this stuff happens where
people you know react to them like that
and sometimes they're crying and shaking
it is just like touches my heart that's
the you know they do tick tock in their
room and how far they reach with this
and it's just really sweet we're having
a lot of fun with it but other than that
you know they still have chores and a
little overwhelming to try and kind of
keep your child focused and have a
normal life as a teenager when this
they're really good kids and we're tight
the four of us and we keep each other
grounded and you know making sure
everybody remembers what's important and
I'm just doing the right thing is there
a number of tick tops or is there a
number of time do you say okay we're
done with tick tock right now we're not
no more no more shooting no more videos
though hey just know they don't feel it
themselves so they know when they
sometimes there the moment hits them and
Charlie I put out 12 and then she won't
do another one for a day so it's just
when it hits her and she's feeling
creative or the same with Dixie and they
just roll with it so they're pretty good
about keeping it balanced
Dixie how has this been for you and what
is it like like the reaction we just
softened that it's a lot of fun and
I feel like it just brought our
relationship like a lot closer we're so
much closer now because we have to do
everything together don't have we get to
do everything together and it's really
fun I mean we've always done things like
cool things as a family so now we just
can't recognize sometimes what has been
your favorite part about this journey so
far way I had there was one specific
thing oh I think probably meeting david
dobrik I really like you right now
dad this is also a business let's not
forget that so how do you handle the
business of it all and how do you manage
the business you know we just take it
slowly and it's a business but it's kind
of funny we were in the twilight of our
parenting I mean we have one kid that
was going off to college another one
that's 15 and now we have to get so
we're in a situation where we're just
taking the offers that come one by one
and not jumping it at anything and and
it but it is a business and they're
going to be set and you know hopefully
I'm not asking you to tell me specific
numbers but what is it what is it Deb
okay what is a tick top what does a tick
tock star make you know the sky's the
limit right now a lot of traditional
brands are switching over from
traditional media over to tick tock
so all those dollars that were being
spent on all other areas of media are
coming to tick tock and other forms but
tick tock being one so the sky's the
limit so has there been anything that
you've done that your mom and dad have
been like I don't know if I want you to
put that tick tock out there oh yeah
just possibly in the songs for being too
inappropriate but they'll tell us and
like we listen because they know what's
best
[Music]